Breaking Bad better call Saul and El
Camino our stories about our capacity
from evil trauma crime deception and
other emotionally interesting things but
Vince Gilligan and his writing teams use
a very process-oriented approach to
writing that focuses on the details of
how characters solve problems to
structure their stories and create
dramatic tension spoilers ahead thank
you so much to Mubi for sponsoring this
video so but now how do we proceed Vince
Gilligan structures the macro arc of his
stories around a character's progression
from A to B to Z his motivation for
writing El Camino shows how the details
of how a character gets from one point
to the next are important events in a
recent interview for Rolling Stone he
said as I was writing the final episode
of Breaking Bad I couldn't help but
wonder where was Jesse driving to as the
months and the years progressed I found
myself a daydreaming about well how
exactly would he have gotten away if you
have Jesse at point-a escaping from the
compound at the end of Breaking Bad how
do you get him to point Z freedom this a
to Z structure exists for each story in
the world of Breaking Bad Breaking Bad
began with the simple concept of mr.
chips becomes Scarface right there you
have your a and your Z the Raiders
establish their characters at point a
and the core of the show becomes
figuring out how to get the character to
point Z better call Saul is a prequel
which gives it a natural z point the
pilot establishes Jimmy McGill and the
core of the show is spent showing how he
gets to point Z obviously having a
character that goes from point A to Z is
not original to Vince Gilligan but my
point here is not that the A to Z exists
in the final product but that Gilligan's
approach to writing involves starting
with a point a and a point Z and then
figuring out what happens in between
those two points
it's not just this approach but the way
gilligan focuses on the details and the
process of how the characters get from
one point to the next and the obstacles
they face along the way that begins to
set his writing apart as identifiably
is tell me why you're doing this
seriously why do you do it money mainly
once you have your a point in your Z
point what makes the steps from point B
to C to Y interesting to the audience
conflict is the foundation of drama and
one way to imbue a character's process
with conflict is to make that process
the solution to a problem this doesn't
mean that the character is necessarily
trying to get to Point C the character
might be aiming for something else and
better call Saul Jimmy isn't trying to
become Saul Goodman but the problems he
faces and his solutions to those
problems will make up the points along
his path towards the final end point a
question of how exactly jesse gets to
Alaska is interesting because it's a
difficult problem for him to solve to do
it he's going to need money and the
details of how he acquires that money
becomes the structural frame of the
story on the surface this is actually
the same frame that both Breaking Bad
and better call Saul start with in each
story the characters need for money is
the initial problem they must solve
where they differ is how each
character's individual quality situation
pride and skills affect the way they
approach solving this larger problem and
the question of why they choose the
solutions that they do provide space for
the core character development for
example in El Camino the Todd flashbacks
reveal a lot of interesting emotional
character moments about both Todd and
Jesse but the narrative motivation for
the
is showing why Jessie looks for the
money at Todd's apartment in Breaking
Bad Walter White starts cooking meth
because it's his solution to not having
the money to pay for chemotherapy but
exploring why he chooses this as a
solution is where the core of his
character development lies for each
character their original solution causes
a cascading series of new problems that
they must work to solve this is the
logic used to progress the story to the
next point let's look at how this
interlocking series of problems and
solutions propels El Camino forward the
main problem Jessi needs to escape
subproblem one jesse is driving a
recognizable car temporary solution hide
it at skinny Pete's house while he
recovers permanent solution get old Joe
to destroy the car this uncovers a new
problem well the car is being tracked
but fortunately skinny Pete has a
solution it's not always the main
character that comes up with the
solution and some of the best character
moments in these shows are when Kim
solves a problem for Jimmy or Jesse
solves a problem for Walt
now that subproblem 1 has been solved
for Jesse he can tackle subproblem 2
finding money to pay Joe that disappear
but I think what really makes the
Gilligan's writing unique is not just
the way he uses problems and solutions
to drive what points b2y will be but the
way he reveals those points to the
audience start fresh in El Camino
Gilligan shows Jesse working towards the
solution of finding Todd's money but at
this point the audience doesn't know
what problem jesse is working towards
solving or what solution jesse is
working towards achieving Gilligan
simply shows the details of Jesse
working towards this goal and lets us
piece together what's happening as it
happens this means that while the
characters follow a very direct a to b2z
progression in the story the audience
may not be shown how these points relate
to each other as
they're happening this is a technique
used frequently throughout breaking bad
and better call Saul the audience is
often shown a character working towards
a specific solution before what the
solution is or what the problem is has
been revealed a great example of this is
in the first episode of better call Saul
season 3 written by Vince Gilligan and
Peter Gould in this episode we get a 6
minute scene of Mike searching for a
tracker on his car the audience is never
told what he's doing once he finds it we
get another scene showing his process to
train the battery on the tracker and
replace it but again none of this is
explained through exposition and why
he's doing it isn't clear until we see
the result at the end of the episode the
sense of discovery you have once you
eventually piece together on your own
how be related to C and C related to D
and realize what the character has been
doing this entire time is one of my
favorite things about watching Breaking
Bad or better call Saul once Jesse finds
the money in Todd's apartment another
problem crops up that he has to deal
with three weeks and you've got your
third jesse doesn't get all the money
and so the money isn't working as a
solution
age one now he has to deal with the
problem of going back to get more money
from the welder three ways but when he
does this he faces the problem of
winning a gunfight to get the money
you're 22 against my 45
but Gilligan doesn't spell out any of
these problems or solutions to the
audience so when he shows Jesse working
to acquire the guns for the showdown
Gilligan doesn't reveal that Jesse
intends to return and get more of the
money or tell us how Jesse intends to
pull this off he just shows Jesse
calling his parents which we then
realize as a distraction so he can find
the key to the house and sneak inside
open the safe and find the guns which he
uses to win the gunfight or shown the
solution to the problem of winning a
gunfight before we know winning a
gunfight is the problem that will need
to be solved when it happens you have
the aha moment of realizing what the
problem was that the character was
working towards earlier and realizing
how they solved that problem
in addition and not making it
immediately clear how one point relates
to the next
Gilligan often reveals to the audience
these points out of order this
non-linear approach is a central aspect
of a Gilligan storytelling and it's been
around since the first scene of Breaking
Bad where we see Walt trying to escape
from a meth cook gone wrong but the
audience doesn't yet know that he was
cooking meth or Y or shone the Z for
that episode first and the rest of that
episode is spent back solving to get us
to that moment we see this again in the
final season where the first scene of
the season reveals Walt working to solve
a problem that won't crop up until the
finale 16 episodes later often while I'm
watching a character on one of these
shows work I think what are they up to
wanting to find out the answer to that
question draws me in makes me pay closer
attention and keeps me hooked and it's a
big part of why Gilligan's focus on
characters process and the details of
work stays interesting and this isn't to
say that this is all that's going on in
these stories dramatically obviously
throughout the shows this technique
isn't always used and sometimes process
or a problem and it's solution or laid
out in a much more straightforward way
and these stories there's inter
character conflict and action that also
creates drama and excitement but in the
world of Breaking Bad I think much of
the drama is supported by the structural
skeleton of Vince Gilligan wanting to
know how exactly does a character get
from point A to B and finally to Z
essential killing is another movie that
follows a man on an escape in a very
procedural A to B to Z way it even uses
flashbacks and flash-forwards in a
manner similar to El Camino to deal with
trauma a central killing is one of the
thirty films available on Mubi right now
every day they add a new indie art house
international cult hit or classic
masterpiece if you want to discover
interesting films of all types and sizes
this is the service you need to be a
part of you can get your extended free
trial when you go to MU be calm slash
Thomas flight
that's mu be calm slash Thomas flight
for your free 30-day trial of MU B
thanks again to MU B for sponsoring this
video thank you for watching thanks so
much to my patreon supporters I want to
quickly plug a new podcast I started
with Jackson from skip intro in Episode
two of the show we both review and
discuss El Camino and talk about what
its presence on Netflix says about
streaming services and how the lines
between TV and movies are starting to
blur check it out and subscribe at
stream theory podcast calm
[Music]